el argumento que utilizó hoy el senador
demócrata es muy hábil en ese sentido
porque el senador trató de mostrar como
el comportamiento de un comandante en
jefe debe ser distinto al de un
incitador en jefe yo creo que ahí van a
ser mucho en fácil los demócratas los
demócratas que van a tratar de demostrar
que el presidente violó su juramento
cuando un presidente jura jura defender
la constitución la ley y a todos los
ciudadanos de los eeuu claramente si
nosotros analizamos los vídeos y la
evidencia de lo que sucedió ese día él
estaba hablando a una parte muy
particular de la audiencia o de los
ciudadanos que se encontraban
congregados en washington desde ese día
e incitó a la violencia es muy difícil
demostrarlo dijeron que van a tener
evidencia específica que van a mostrar
nuevos vídeos y ahí es donde habrá un
profundo debate acerca de si eso es
suficiente o no hay un elemento que
puede ser
es importante tener en cuenta las
encuestas de opinión durante el primer
impacto en que se llevó a cabo que se le
llevó a cabo de una lesión no llegaron a
tener un 51 por ciento de aprobación
actualmente esa aprobación de un
impeachment y de una condena llega al 56
por ciento el problema es que dentro del
partido republicano el 80% de los
republicanos considera que donarán sigue
siendo un líder legítimo de ese partido
y el 61 por ciento afirma que las
elecciones en efecto fueron robadas ahí
es donde el problema de la retórica y de
los hechos particulares que un show